[Music]
an average of 30 container ships has sat
anchored daily
just off the coast of los angeles this
year the normal number of
container ships at anchor is zero to one
this ship the everfront not to be
confused with the now famous ever given
was waiting for 13 days seeing vessels
at anchorage outside the nation's
largest container port
does not happen every day and it is a
once in about a decade
situation that we see everfront was part
of a bottleneck in the supply chain
that's still straining the neighboring
ports
which handle about a third of all u.s
imports i don't think it's an
exaggeration to say that the ports have
never really seen
this confluence of stresses that they've
had to deal with
so what's causing this offshore cue how
do these waiting ships impact customers
onshore
and when will it return to normal i
think we got here because
we all had to stay home experts say if
there's one cause for the backup
it's covet 19. staying home leads you to
go
all right my desk isn't great if i've
got one my chair isn't comfortable even
if i've got one
i might need a new computer monitor i
might need
a webcam actually i can't go to the gym
so i'm going to go buy
a peloton or a running machine or some
dumbbells
for many americans that has meant
placing online orders for those items
most of which aren't made in the u.s
seaborn imports to the u.s
started surging in the late summer as
manufacturers and retailers tried to
rebuild inventories that were depleted
by shoppers in the early months of the
pandemic
we had 57 extra ships arrive in the fall
above normal levels which choked the
system
because at that same time the goods
movement system assure
the terminals the trains the trucks the
warehouses the forklift drivers
had some fraction of the workforce out
with kovid
and a different fraction out because of
contact tracing
so just when there's more cargo there's
a less efficient
goods movement the system ashore so the
ships backed up
but shipments continued peaking in
february when 177 container ships
carrying more than 800
000 containers arrived at the southern
california ports
that's 31 percent more ships and 49
more containers than the same month last
year
this gap highlights a related issue the
ships
are getting bigger there's been a
significant increase in the number of
the very biggest boats that come in i'm
also very efficient when they're
at sea they're a devil to unpack and a
devil to park
and so it takes longer to get all of
them sorted out
so the ships continue to wait an average
of seven and a half days before reaching
the port
and that means consumers are waiting too
okay peloton let's go
this is something buyers of peloton
bikes may already know
the company said in its latest earnings
report that backups contributed to
recent shipping delays
i'm sure you've seen that on a lot of
e-commerce sites it's taking us longer
than normal to
deliver to you and so you know there's
that kind of customer disappointment
angle and companies will then need to
think okay how do i avoid that in the
future
time come on let's get this workout
started for peloton the answer has been
to spend more
the company said it would spend 100
million dollars in transportation
including air shipments in the first
half of the year to get around the
bottlenecks of the port mom and pop
retailers also have products they'd hope
to sell
stuck on these ships and many of the
smallest shops
can't afford to fly products in instead
but the ships
aren't the only issue here the entire
supply chain from ports to warehouses to
distribution centers
is inundated with cargo so if the cargo
is not moving
quickly from the ship to the shore out
through the warehouses to the consumer
everything else is going to start to
back up this congestion which was driven
by demand for shipping
also means that the cost of shipping has
gone up
the current global average shipping rate
is nearly four times what it was in
january 2020 according to data from s p
global platz someone's going to pay for
that it's either going to come off
company's profits
or they're going to pass it through to
consumers the longer it lasts
the more likely it is that consumers are
going to pay it
at the ports workers are pushing to get
the anchor chips moving
pre-pandemic we were welcoming on
average
10 container vessels in to work at the
port
loading and unloading containers every
day during this surge
we've been averaging 15 vessels working
every day in the port
that's a 50 percent jump in productivity
alongside our vessels every day
sirocca says the port's short-term
strategy focuses on vaccinating workers
maximizing efficiencies and asking
importers to more quickly pick up cargo
that he predicts will help clear the
backlog of ships by this summer
any longer could bring more problems we
have a short window here before our
traditional peak season kicks off
in august for back to school other
retail requirements and the
all-important year-end holiday
with americans receiving a fresh round
of stimulus this bottleneck could
intensify
and how states and the federal
government proceed with reopening
may impact that if we're going to spend
another summer lockdown then people are
going to be buying
you know new lawn chairs and a whole
bunch of stuff they didn't buy
last year if everything's open again and
people can go on vacation
it's all services spending we're not
going to buy stuff
so the demand for shipping will drop off
relatively quickly